Richard you wanted to make a toast yes
yes yes yeah you don't have to put your
legs down No
now what's your job you just hold his
letter have to hold them up yeah and I
swirled the champagne down his [ __ ]
very nice job
what a great deal Howard I'll make this
short and sweet how it's really it all
goes in it's an amazing noise it makes
- just do a little bit into his [ __ ]
you can hear the noise Richard go ahead
make your toes Howard I'll make it short
and sweet so you don't have to stare at
my [ __ ] too long
congratulations on your book and thank
you for everything you do you've made
millions of people happy every morning
for a very long time and that's
something that nobody else in
entertainment can say you deserve all
the praise that comes with this capper
to your incredible career and I know
deep down you're very proud of
everything you've done and you should be
cheers how I cheer
[Music]
okay it's far in juice I'm worried about
the champagne not the arms so why you
really absorbing cutting you I'm cutting
your [ __ ] long this is a beautiful
tribute for Howard Stern comes again
thank you so much I love it
[Music]